[Music]
all right someone else grateful for
where he is wrestler turned actor
Johnson he's back on the big screen in
his new comedy blockers and I gotta warn
everybody I get again ready you're about
to see a whole lot of Cena uncensored so
what about a little chugging contest
yeah you guys bring it
I heard took six hours to shoot yeah it
was looking all night thing six hours to
shoot six days to clean this outrageous
chugging contest has an r-rated twist
and John winds up with his shorts around
his ankles I know what executives get
into I'm gonna spend the night with my
pants off he's fine with that there I am
Stan it's the wind yeah I never want you
there are those of us who have limits
No Limits is what blockers is all about
in the comedy John Leslie Mann and Ike
Barinholtz play parents who discovered
that their daughters made up all night
pact to lose their virginity I want to
go to prom get drunk
potted up on weed and lose my virginity
we're gonna have the same first time sex
anniversary we can go to dinner everyone
commemorate it I can Leslie you guys are
parents to two daughters each so could
you relate to your characters at all
yeah a little bit I mean I I track my
kids but on find my friends which is
that's normal right I mean it it's
normal for me it's better at all I think
it's normal
our girls are not thinking things
through I'm gonna stop them
I'm in CHEM you tracking your kids we
all have the same iCloud account app are
you tracking your kids I'm tracking
another bunny walkers opens April 6 come
on man I get it I get it
[Music]